[Music]
you'll request that I would send you an
account of my uncle's death in order to
transmit a more exact relation of it to
posterity deserves my acknowledgments
for if this accident shall be celebrated
by your pen the glory of it I'm well
assured will be rendered forever
illustrious and notwithstanding he
perished by a misfortune which as it
involved at the same time a most
beautiful country in ruins and destroyed
so many populous cities seems to promise
him an everlasting remembrance
notwithstanding he has himself composed
many and lasting works yet I am
persuaded the mentioning of him in your
immortal writings will greatly
contribute to render his name immortal
he was at that time with the fleet under
his command at Messina on the 24th of
August about 1:00 in the afternoon
my mother desired him to observe a cloud
which appeared of a very unusual size
and shape he had just taken a turn in
the Sun and after bathing himself in
cold water and making a light luncheon
gone back to his books he immediately
arose and went out upon a rising ground
from whence he might get a better sight
of this very uncommon appearance a cloud
from which Mountain was uncertain at
this distance but it was found
afterwards to come from Mount Vesuvius
was ascending the appearance of which I
cannot give you a more exact description
now by likening it to that of a pine
tree for it shot up to a great height in
the form of very tall trunk which spread
itself out at the top into a sort of
branches occasioned I imagine either by
a sudden gust of air that impelled it
the force of which decreased as it
advanced upwards or the cloud itself
being pressed back again by its own
weight expanded in the manner I've
mentioned it appeared sometimes sprite
and sometimes dark and spotted cooling
as it was either more or less
impregnated
earth and cinders this phenomenon seemed
to a man of such learning and research
as my uncle extraordinary and worth
further looking into
he ordered a light vessel to be got
ready and gave me leave if I like to
accompany him I said I'd rather go on
with my work and it so happened he
himself given me something to write out
as he was coming out of the house he
received a note from rectina the wife of
bassist who was in the utmost alarm at
the imminent danger which threatened her
for her Villa lying at the foot of Mount
Vesuvius there was no way of escape but
by the sea she earnestly entreated him
therefore to come to her assistance he
accordingly changed his first intention
and what do you begun from a
philosophical he now carries out in a
noble and generous spirit he ordered the
galleys to be put to sea and went
himself on board with an intention of
assisting not only rectina for the
several other towns which lay thickly
strewn along that beautiful coast
[Music]
hastening then to the place from whence
others fled with the utmost terror he
steered his course direct to the point
of danger and with so much calmness and
presence of mind as to be able to make
and dictate his observations upon the
motion and all the phenomena of that
dreadful scene he was now so close to
the mountain that the cinders which grew
thicker and hotter the nearer he
approached fell into the ships together
with Pumas stones and black pieces of
burning rock they were in danger too not
only of being a ground by the sudden
retreat of the sea but also from the
vast fragments which rolled down from
the mountain and obstructed all the
shore here he stopped to consider
whether he should turn back again to
which the pilot advising him fortune
said he favors the brave steer to where
Pomponio nurses
pompon Yanis was then its star be a
separated by obey which the see after
several insensible windings forms with
the shore he'd already sent his baggage
on board for though he was not at the
time in actual danger yet being within
sight of it and indeed extremely near if
it shouldn't at least increase he was
determined to put to sea as soon as the
wind which was blowing dead in shore
would go down
it was favourable however for carrying
my uncle to pompon yarnís whom he found
in the greatest consternation he
embraced him tenderly encouraging him
and urging him to keep up his spirits
and the more effectually to soothe his
fears by seeming unconcerned himself or
with a path to be got ready and then
after having bathed sat down to supper
with great cheerfulness or at least what
is just as heroic with every appearance
of it meanwhile broad flames shone out
in several places from Mount Vesuvius
which the darkness of the night
contributed to render still brighter and
clearer but my uncle in order to soothe
the apprehensions of his friend assured
him it was only the burning of the
villages which the country people had
abandoned to the flames after this he
retired to rest and it is most certain
he was so little disquieted as to fall
into a sound sleep for his breathing
watch on account of his corpulence was
rather heavy and sonorous was heard by
the attendants outside
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the court which led to his apartment
being now almost filled with stones and
ashes if he had continued there any time
longer it would have been impossible for
him to have made his way out so he was
awoke and got up feeling too anxious to
think of going to bed they consulted
together where there would be most
prudent to trust the houses which now
rocked from side to side with frequent
and violent concussions as though shaken
from their very foundations or fly to
the open fields whether calcined stones
and cinders though light indeed fell in
large showers and threatened to
destruction in this choice of dangers
they resolved for the fields the
resolution which while the rest of the
company were hurried into by their fears
my uncle embraced upon cool and
deliberate consideration they went out
then having pillows tied about their
heads with napkins and this was their
whole defense against the storm of
stones that fell round them it was now
day everywhere else but there was a
deeper darkness prevailed and in the
thickest night which however was in some
degree alleviated by torches and other
lights of various kinds they thought
proper to go farther down upon the shore
to see if they might safely put out to
sea but found the waves still running
extremely high and boisterous there my
uncle
laying himself down upon a sail cloth
which was spread for him called twice
for some cold water which he drank when
immediately the flames proceeded by a
strong smell of sulphur dispersed the
rest of the party and obliged him to
rise he raised himself up with the
assistance of two of his servants and
instantly fell down dead suffocated as I
conjecture by some gross and noxious
vapor having always had a weak throat
which was often inflamed
[Music]
as soon as it was light again which was
not till the third day after this
melancholy accident his body was found
in tyre and without any marks of
violence upon it in the dress in which
he fell and looking more like a man
asleep than dead
[Music]
during all this time my mother and I who
were at Miss enum but this has no
connection with your history and you did
not desire any particulars besides those
of my uncle's death so I will end here
only adding that I have faithfully
related to you what was either an eye
witness of myself or received
immediately after the accident happened
and before there was time to bury the
truth he will pick out of this narrative
whatever is most important for a letter
is one thing history another it is one
thing writing to a friend
another thing writing to the public
farewell
[Music]
you